hi my name is greg and i'm john and we
are with the real rejects hi guys hi
zach um this is truly an honor i grew up
on um i watched all the scrubs watched
guard and stayed a bunch thanks man
yeah we're just going to read your items
you're going in style we're doing this
man
um yeah and uh we're telling gail this
like we're we're obviously not the
typical target demographic for this
movie but then we found ourselves we
were like really hesitant to watch it
and then we found ourselves both really
charmed by it and found it really sweet
and funny so it is it's heartwarming and
you know i i think it's cool that
disney's putting it out it's such it's
such a you know it doesn't shy away from
what it's like to be a blended family in
2022 and all the different things that
could come up and yeah i mean i mean
it's amazing how much kenya packs into
the screenplay and the kids are
hilarious and
you know mostly for parents it's just
it's the ultimate example of something
like you are you're gonna laugh you're
not gonna sit there and roll your eyes
at oh my goodness i have to watch this
with my kid you're gonna laugh your butt
off i think absolutely and i was
wondering like i feel like a role like
yours in a film like this it could
easily feel perfunctory but between the
writing and your performance i thought
you struck a great balance of fun and
relatability while also supporting the
ensemble so how did you go about
building a uh uniquely blended family
dynamic with gabrielle and the rest of
your coaches well gab and i quit right
off the bat she's just cool and she's
fun and she's you know she's just
you can't say anything that'll shock her
in fact she'll say something that'll
shock you and i love kids i don't have
any of my own but i was like you know
uncle zack and she really has kids so
she was more like the mom
she's the one who had to be like zach
you're getting them all riled up come on
come on come on
but um you know we we just we had a
great balance it was the pandemic we
were so thrilled to be able to make
something you know uh as performers as
someone who attempts to make people
laugh to finally be on a set again and
doing that with little kids and they
were so cute and what's great about kids
is you can give them a joke that comes
to your mind and sound like an insult as
you would never go to a fellow actor
like say they say that say this
i just came up with back to me with a
little kid you can be like say this and
then i'm gonna say this and they would
do it and it would be hilarious and
you'd get all this like there's a moment
when the kid i'm like how did you get
down here and he goes the laundry shoot
i go we have a laundry shoot like me and
that kid just improv that together well
and probably together oh that's great i
told him to say he took the laundry
shoot yeah i was gonna say then with you
being a director yourself did you ever
find that you wanted to slip into that
role i was very careful my nightmare is
whenever i'm an actor that a director
will feel like i'm gonna step on their
toes at all so so gail and i had a great
synergy occasionally i would whisper in
her ear like you should have so-and-so
do that it'd be hilarious or there's a
really cool camera position over here
for that joke and you know but but never
never overstep my my my my bounds with
it yeah that's fun you know you actually
had he had a question in mind that i
thought was really fun yeah okay so your
character obviously is a chef and a
sauce connoisseur so i am curious
do you have a sauce recipe of your own
or just a favorite sauce and when will
we expect to see you on hot ones
um i don't think i could hail hot ones
yeah i've been getting a lot of requests
to go on hot ones and i look at it it
looks so painful
um
you know we watched watching watch you
suffer
zach when can we see you suffer
um sauce-wise i'm not really you know
i'm i'm a big sweet guy i have a sweet
tooth so and i love peanut butter and
chocolate so it's probably already
invented reese's peanut butter cup sauce
but that's what i would do i would just
drench like a sundae with peanut butter
and chocolate sauce
my last question is is like with with
the kids that you were working with in
particular i know like a common trait is
like ah you know you don't have a
favorite here but was there a kid here
in particular that you felt like we
really clicked them up yeah leo he
played he played uh uh luca he just
he's just the sweetest kid i've ever met
in my life he's an incredible dancer and
he's so smart and he he's the kind of
kid we would sit and just have like a
very grown-up chat about things and then
and then they'd call us to our marks and
we'd go over and he goes
that was a nice chat zach
[Laughter]
he's like nine going on 40.
you're gonna have like a monthly call
when we do we hung out you know i mean
he's got a um you know he had never been
to disneyland so i took him and his mom
at disneyland with my friends and uh i
just love him he's the sweetest kid i
ever met uh yeah this this movie was fun
and uh even though you're not a dad
yourself you sure as hell play a great
one you're like man it seems like i
could be a hell of a dad i would be
happy to get your son yeah
so thank you you guys should check out
uh our me and donald's podcast uh fake
doctor's real friends we we we uh watch
old school episodes i've heard all about
that yeah absolutely i grew up down the
street from the hospital so
i'm gonna finish all of those tonight
check it out it
all right thank you zach for your time
and thank you congrats on the movie this
is thanks thank you
hi i'm greg and i'm john and we are the
real rejects uh gail gail thank you uh
for taking the time to speak with us um
i think i can speak for both of us on
this end uh we'll be honest
when we were walking into this we were
like
i don't know about this
we are not the target audience we're not
talking right so i don't know
by the time
it's sort of why i laughed when i first
saw you guys i was like oh boy either
or i am in for a roasting so thank you
will there be more action in the second
one
[Laughter]
well no i mean like one of the main
things i really loved about this movie
was
i would say the level of support that
was demonstrated throughout the film
like even at times where one would
expect a like generic conflict to come
up it would sort of divert and it was
refreshing to like flip the script on
showing love in a tough situation
instead of a generic conflict so it did
make me curious with the amount of heart
in this movie
what were some of the main messages you
intentionally wanted to convey to the
audience or wanted them to take away
well the biggest one is i think it's
really tempting to think that we need to
have more and give our families more
like
more money a bigger house more sneakers
you know just more success
and i think that really what the movie
comes down to saying is kids want more
time they want more attention they want
more you
and we didn't set out to make like a
cats in the cradle movie where
everyone's crying and saying i wish i
were a better parent but just that at
the end of the movie you want to spend
more time with your kids is really our
goal and then one thing that was really
important to me and i think it gets
slept on a little bit because we do a
lot of really interesting social
commentary i love the scene with the two
dads talking about the true limitations
of a white dad trying to parent a black
son that no matter how
aware you are no matter how much love
and focus you give it no matter how
educated you are about it you just lack
that lived experience so like that's a
wonderful scene i feel like a lot of
people will talk about that scene but a
scene that i just adore is the character
of dom you know he has these natural
natural connections to his daughter
who's this amazing athlete and his son
who's like a comic book nerd he just
doesn't really know what to do about him
and partially because he's just on the
road and not around and also because he
can't relate to d d and comic books that
they've just sort of kept their distance
but the actor andre who plays dj was so
vulnerable
and tree who plays dom is so warm
originally their reconciliation scene
was much shorter
and i was like these guys need more you
know when we expanded the scene and made
it bigger and i'm like oh you are really
going out on a lid we're gonna go to
comic-con that is as far out of your
comfort zone as imaginable and i just
love that scene so much i think that was
excellent i i mean one of the things i
loved was how it didn't actually shy
away from like the racial discussions i
thought it might have just been like oh
maybe just a casting thing but then
you're like oh no it's integrated within
the story which made it that much more
nuanced i would say absolutely and uh
you know kind of piggybacking off of
that you know you have a lot of things
to balance you know obviously you have
all the different kids and the
personalities and the energy they bring
and that's part of the charm so what was
your approach to balancing that with
like the the you know zach and
gabrielle's story is to me kind of like
a through line that anchors everything
together so what was the approach to
balancing all of those personalities and
keeping it you know succinct
i think there were a couple things we
really had to
help the kids learn the importance of
like staying focused
because we have such limited hours with
them yeah and also you know they tend to
just go into like play mode goof around
mode and
i don't know about you guys but when i
was a kid when someone said be quiet it
would just wind me up more to want to
act out more
but i really found that when i explained
to them why they had to be quiet because
it helped their scene partner it freed
up their brain to think about funny
things to do
they really got it and it was amazing
because they learned from zach and gab
who are such great veterans at that and
they really were like oh we want to be
on a team you know we want to
get in on the fun and not just be told
like quiet
yeah
absolutely
and that was great and there was just
one thing i'll say about a challenge of
working with kids is that they say you
know every actor needs a different
director and it's your job to be every
single different director that they need
and there was one child actor who i will
not name
he was usually so focused and a great
listener
and there was a thing that i thought was
simple and he just could not do it he
was unfocused
at points i would even tell him try
saying it like this and he just could
not and i was like what's going on this
is not like him
and then i thought of it and i went up
and i was like honey do you have to use
the bathroom
and he said
yes miss gail i do
and
he's like but i know there's no time and
i said there's always time for you to be
a person
go take care of it
and he came back and he nailed it and i
just thought this might be my proudest
moment as a director i saw what my actor
needed he needed to pee
you're talking about zach braf aren't
you
oh no yeah this film uh surprised us and
i mean it sincerely it was it was
actually really delightful and i laughed
quite a bit throughout as well so
that's so nice tell your friends tell
your audience absolutely for the nephews
i will tell most i will most definitely
be doing that thank you gail for your
time and uh thank you for delivering on
this movie and uh enjoy the rest of the
the junket you have today you too guys
thank you so much so fun to talk to you
it's time for photography too thank you
take care